we made a crazy little trip to Morocco
if your real [ __ ] Army flagrance
reporter you already know what the [ __ ]
time it was
um we pulled off some incredible [ __ ] so
Morocco was gonna play or did play
France yep in the semi-finals yeah now
Morocco is this massive Underdog
um I love underdogs I love the Underdog
Story it motivates me it excites me I
love the energy around underdogs
everything about the what if moment
excites me and we were gonna go watch
the game in Qatar the reason why we're
not in Qatar right now is because this
is my first year anniversary with my
wife yeah
which is fire and is awesome but um we
had to watch you know the game but I
didn't want to go out there to Qatar and
then my wife's got to wear a [ __ ]
garbage bag for the whole weekend or
whatever it's not the best way to
celebrate your first anniversary it
helps gratitude in America though great
things are yeah that's a good ass point
I could just turn the thing around she
can't see it all I just run and go watch
the game yeah do they ever play that
game
they're just walking then flip the
garbage bag around and then it's just
nothing you see absolutely nothing
that's a really fun prank yeah yeah we
should do that is a fun prank
you don't think that that's a fun wild
dude is that why is that wild it's kind
of a funny prank yeah do you know what's
enough yeah anyway so uh so we're
talking about we're like do we want to
go to Qatar we're like no I don't really
want to go to Qatar I mean no offense
guitar but like it didn't feel like the
energy was there like it didn't feel
like there was the people that were
there like if I'm gonna watch this game
we're gonna go out and watch a game I
want to watch it with the people so it
was either we go to Paris and watch the
French people watch France go against
Morocco it's obviously Mark wants to go
Alex was thinking about going as well or
we go to Morocco now the energy around
an underdog is so much better also one
of my best friends in the entire world
happens to be a Moroccan so we do have
an affinity for Moroccans okay now who
better it's right here come on bro he's
barely fans the guy Doug was Moroccan
until we went to Morocco we realized
those people are Morocco yeah
you can't speak
oh my fridge was nice
that was rough that was an e-port
episode
you did he pluribus him yeah anyway so
um the night before uh the the night the
night before no two nights before the
game I messaged everybody I go bring a
passport a pair of underwear to the
podcast because we still have to report
record the podcast we didn't have any
tickets book we had none of that [ __ ]
and um I'm talking to Dove all night
like can we [ __ ] pull this off can we
go do it and there's a the Vlog that's
probably out right now some of you guys
go check it out we vlogged the whole
experience it's really wild and so we
decide we go [ __ ] it we come to the Pod
we basically right before the podcast
starts I think agree to go was it right
before was even during
yeah yeah that was a little stress yeah
yeah yeah yeah why was that stressed I
don't know
why you look so stressed though
you mean because Andrew wants to leave
in a few hours to Morocco with six guys
during the World Cup in a city that no
one's been to with equipment we don't
have out there yet or the place not to
view it yet
hold on that will be fun and then he had
to do that while we were of course
everyone was a little stressed I think
like Akash played it off well but I
could see him a couple times being like
can we do it oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
you don't like to travel yo you don't
like to travel you're a great sport like
nobody's a better sport than you yeah
but that's that's not true zero notice
to go to Africa you don't like to travel
yeah I haven't I committed and I thought
it was gonna be so dope and then the
night of the night we commit and then
the day I was like yo we're going to
[ __ ] Africa and all I got is a
couple pairs of underwear and a
toothbrush what the [ __ ] is happening
this it's an adventure baby yeah it was
but I was like God damn it's a lot yo
we're doing a lot to be honest Burning
Man Morocco Morocco not even [ __ ]
close I disagree but
but anyway we go I'm just about to
listen to this [ __ ] and only
packed underwear oh yeah I didn't have a
two Fame yeah that was the most nights
and here's the best part we all had
backpacks I was trying to look at Andrew
he's got a backpack and a bag yeah we
travel for a living we have the right
carry-on bag with the right thing and
Andrew's like you know just bring your
toothbrush and this now look at him look
like a homeless at the corner I have to
lift the [ __ ] heavy stuff all this
money in look what we packed our bags
this is more exciting we're going to
Africa we're just taking a backpack
isn't that way cooler than everybody
with their little roll-on bags God
forbid you have to cross it over
yourself this is what he's breaking from
New York this is Christmas yeah because
not everything fit because I need to
support kid super unlike you selfish
pieces of [ __ ] oh I can't roll my back
they don't have streets where we're
going what are you gonna do wait I gotta
get my favorite angle here stop I'm not
gonna because I had to bring kids super
stuff because we're going to meet kids
super shout out to Colin cow's the kid
uh and uh and kid super was also very
motivational in this piece he was like
yo it'd be so much more fire if we watch
that [ __ ] Morocco yeah so it was like
all right let's do it and he flew from
Brazil bruh that day like 18 years Spain
to some other [ __ ] eventually gets to
Morocco yeah he meets us the next day
but we go on this flight and Dove is a
master of [ __ ] trailer guys booked
flights for [ __ ] years he's lived in
Europe every second but the guy's Master
like he if there's an if there's a
flight to be found this [ __ ]
will find it I'm excited I'm actually
excited to have about seven hours where
I could just chill I'm taking his red
eye we get on this flight
that [ __ ] takes off I was searching I
was searching for some Wi-Fi before the
flight took off and I was like you know
that Wi-Fi probably gonna pop up yeah
we're not at 10 000 feet yeah we're just
yeah why is it playing have a Verizon
Wi-Fi that's weird yeah yeah this is oh
odd odd thing right I I opened up at 10
I asked the lady I was like yo we had
ten thousand fishes because I didn't
even want to know the bad news I wanted
to see for myself you had a lady flight
attendant yeah only men oh no they were
doing that business class my boy I
noticed that was only dudes and I was
like huh I wonder what that was about
they were not happy about it yeah they
were they were kerfuffled wait really on
my side there were there was a big fan
of Schultz so he just kept slipping me
wine get out of here no he said Dude
shows got recognizing Morocco so much it
was amazing it was amazing she wasn't
living he wasn't slipping you one
because he knew you he was slipping wine
because Dove goes oh yeah that's my best
friend
just try to first get him to get me into
business class and that was a
constellation there's something about
going closer to the Homeland that just
brings out the negotiator and then like
he's already he was haggling with the
pilot he was like can I just sit behind
you yeah
come on yeah you want me
I'll DJ let me play music come on pass
off so we get on this flight of course
there's no internet [ __ ] seven hours
yeah okay
we deal with it
we land
go to almost missed the flight oh [ __ ]
that's right we got to go Casablanca to
Marrakesh yeah we finally get to
Marrakesh
um and then what the [ __ ] happens
we went straight to the Riyadh oh yeah
Medina
yes yes so Dove got this beautiful
Riyadh that's in the Medina shout out to
munim do we know the name of it if you
guys ever go to Marrakech
and it's like a five Sweet Boutique
Hotel
we have the whole service it was the
whole hotel remember showing us the roof
oh yeah
wow awesome would it be possible to show
them the roof can I show them the roof
not bad
what bro
what's really cool about some of these
little stores is that they look tiny
upon the entrance but then they open up
look at this
it's just this insane place that has
been built over I don't know probably
thousands of [ __ ] years like yeah you
could never design a place like this you
know like culture just needs to create a
place like this developing organically
over thousands a lot of rugs that's not
a stereotype no they love rugs no I love
a carpet yeah export yeah yeah yeah like
a real a lot of carpet carpet what is it
what is a carpet bro what do you think
came first the love of rugs or having to
pray five times a day whoa that's a good
ass Point bro because you know what I'm
saying did prayer five times a day was
that way they were like this is cool man
right notice in this rug I'm thinking
about rugs a lot or was there like a rug
dealer that like hit up Muhammad and he
was like yo can we up at a few I need
some wear and tear in these rugs you
know what's moving better than playing
four times
I'm just saying we have to look at that
yeah I'm curious I think the rugs were
probably made prior Islam comes around
like what 500 A.D sure 680 why not like
let's go with that right yeah people
have rugs before that Aladdin was flying
around in like zero yeah exactly I don't
know how you know Aladdin wasn't Muslim
he wasn't okay good point you won
Ottoman Empire that's a great argument
the [ __ ] he was Muslim wasn't he was he
Muslim yeah he had to be Muslim yeah I
mean he wears a fez right
no there's a Latin wear a fez the yeah I
think I think he does he might wear it
fast like a little one I think anywho
that's a Moroccan dude it was just dope
walking around the souk we walk around
the souk we go to the square yeah yeah
and the square is crazy the square is
crazy yeah that's what we're gonna watch
again yeah yeah and during the day it
kind of seems like kind of chills for a
low-key it's like Times Square of
Morocco of Marrakesh yep and then the
snake Charmers but instead of billboards
he had snakes and monkeys and there's
literal cobras they're just sitting the
square and they're not attached to
nothing
to take pictures with yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I was super confident I was
surprised how confident you were with
this yeah you're really good with snakes
bro yeah no I'm just saying I was
surprised How brave you were why were
you so [ __ ] when this thing what
happened relax what happened pushed me
in I didn't push you there's no proof of
that push me it took over you know I
don't know first of all you have no
balance bro you want to take this
outside 1v1 you right now
like what's good
I gave out a little nudge and the Cobra
is staring at him and then bro the way
that you freaked out bro he grabbed his
ankle trying to get a yellow card it was
they know they were coming for the snake
bro they know it the music's getting
louder
hi everybody
okay we're here I don't even know what
to say right now oh that one keeps going
down
yes
oh [ __ ] what's going on
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
dude then so we do the snakes and this
is a really annoying thing about the
snakes and about the monkeys as well is
that like
The Experience being with them is
incredible
like there's a [ __ ] Cobra right in
front of you yes right you are
photobombing a cobra it's pretty
remarkable you're seeing it right there
there's nothing stopping it I'm sure
they defang them or do some horribly
yeah animal cruelty [ __ ] to them but
whatever but there's something about
being around come on because the guys
around it were very afraid of it too
yeah dude was throwing [ __ ] rugs and
[ __ ] on top of it to calm it down
like he was afraid of it too so if he's
afraid of it and he's the [ __ ] yeah
I'm not going near that you think the
Charmin does anything I don't think so
no the drugs do something though oh yeah
they must be drunk on these guys yeah
but the snakes are still up yeah yeah
like this is going after ecstasy yes
Raven dude but just here they just think
they're at a like EDM festival and they
just hear the music and they're just
they start playing the [ __ ] flute
they think it's blondish man I'm telling
you
they were into it it was fire it was
fake I thought that was only in the
cartoons but I will say I really do the
worst thing about it is the way that
they kind of hustle you when they leave
oh you didn't like that I did not like
it man because it's like all it would
take is one group of them because
there's a bunch of different like snake
Charmers one group to not do that and
then you would tell people to go to that
group every single time they want a
picture with a snake but like they hust
you they leave their like hold Port I
think that's true what's that if there
was one group you think you would go and
tell people like yo when you go to
Morocco yeah find this group to take the
snake yeah it's like don't go to the guy
TripAdvisor Snake Charmer group the guy
with the beard in the Hat
these guys are trying to make money
however they can make it they're just
that's why they're so aggressive it's a
I'm not that I liked it but I get why
it's happening but you didn't like it
though I didn't like it no maybe if
there was one that you would like you
would like tell people to go back I
wouldn't tell where's the apple pie it
would be like the 10th thing on my list
of tell to tell people in Morocco where
to get snake Charmed right yes yes
right okay give me the other nine at
least no no give me the other nine
things that you're gonna tell me where
to buy a jalaba where to eat well I
don't know where you could buy one every
[ __ ] store you walk by in the suit
just ask anyway these aggressive guys
there
they're annoying at those stores too and
you think you're paying for snake
charming twice say what you're gonna do
that snake trying to think twice you're
gonna go to one guy like I had a bad
experience let me try the next guy he's
saying like who's gonna do that he's
saying it's a referral based business
yeah I think it is referral based though
did you sign the exit four I said you've
been in Morocco twice didn't even know
I didn't take no picture with snakes the
first time I was there what are you
doing the first time I had a wife
I'm not doing that risk making it
yeah
I can't do that [ __ ] but then we went to
the he was an activist before he was
like this cruel animals this is cruel to
these monkeys
he kept pulling me aside he's like yo
that Palms are so soft I was like you
not allowed to happen you I'm not
allowed to get a monkey if you say you
getting a pet monkey bro I'm calling the
authorities yeah you getting that banana
Beach
yeah
[Laughter]
if you're listening right now and you're
a girl and you ever meet Dove and I'm
there I will for sure throw the
alley-oop to dub by making you touch his
hands it's one of my favorite things to
help you get [ __ ]
yeah you need the help has that ever
gotten me posted is it is it though I
mean
yo this is the other thing that he yo
Dove first of all if you're a fan of
this podcast you support this podcast or
you come out to the stand-up shows
they'll forgot about you
what do you mean what do you mean don't
forgot about you if you hooked up with
Dove oh okay he forgot isn't that crazy
is
actually say
s never hooked up with a fan of the
podcast yeah
[Applause]
okay say it again I'm gonna not talk if
you keep doing it
what do you think he's supposed to do
he's shooting out on purpose like that
like on purpose like what I would never
like what you're that much closer you're
gonna get your nose bruh that's what I'm
saying that's what every girl sees
isn't it yeah but it's multiple girls do
you see how that works in my life but
what were you saying what was the story
you have sex with a lot of fans or
something like that no fans you've never
had sex with a fan of the pot not one
time I hooked you up with a fan of the
Pod you just couldn't close that's on
you she had a boyfriend so you've never
slept with a fan of the pot or like a
fan of the stand-up
not one time I met a girl
stop [ __ ] my fans bro bro that's a
little bit that's why that's just I want
everyone to not one time like white why
even cat why cap it's such a lie
it's really not good that's all you got
it's it but it's actually not true I've
met a girl at a comedy club and you were
one of the showcased artists but it
wasn't your show it wasn't the podcast
she happened to have an Android shirt
that's coincidental coincidental the DMS
aren't coincidental but I'm not hooked
up with that so they don't like him yeah
you've lobbed me up in a non-podcast
comedy way but not I'm good I'm a good
Wing man but I'm just speaking facts but
am I a good way man or am I not oh
cautious better
wow I'm Legit I'm legitimately one of
the best Wing men ever wow I can't
believe that that's real wow
just a birds
can I tell the story
baby we went down to do a show in Philly
Dove took a girl down to Philly to go
watch the show right yeah the girls get
a ride back to New York with Mark
because Doug's such a cheap [ __ ] he
don't want to pay for Uber back to New
York right so he gets a ride back to it
with Mark
never talking
so don't just goes Mark what were you
talking to this girl about that made her
decide that she never needs to see me
again so I bet yo what's the opposite of
which I bet they still talk just not
platonically of course but I would still
maintain a friendship neither yeah yeah
I'm friends with dub friends bro that's
all yeah what was the other one
unbelievable oh yeah Dove brought a girl
into the studio yeah and then and the
way Mark and her are chatting I assume
she's like about to get a job here
because they're just having a formal
lengthy discussion and then I talked to
Dove and he's like yeah I brought her
here after a date and then Mark has been
talking to her for two hours
one-on-one he goes I just had to leave
that's the horse Wing man
they were just up like just chatting the
words worse just Chad and it's just so
shitty because you're a great husband
and you have no interest in these women
and you just still talk to him and waste
everyone's time just chatting we're just
chatting itself
the guy just chatting dude but how do
you find a way to talk everybody out of
[ __ ]
if I ain't getting none of nobody
when you turned a Psychology major and
after you read the game he got [ __ ]
though he did yeah
but that's why it's worse than Mark does
it you don't think that I was opening up
the door for them to him to go all along
so he wouldn't got no [ __ ] without you
is what you say I helped him
back in college
he said you may have no reason College
was crazy
I had suspenders
oh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
bro it's like she got a friend the girl
I'm talking to got a friend some lonely
ass girl needs you
what do you mean like okay
he just kept throwing you allies
that's it
Alice translating really well right now
you're translating it perfectly I don't
get no [ __ ] [ __ ] selling Cable
packages
they got the free Shadows
you have to free Channel your way into
[ __ ]
that's not magic Abracadabra here's
everything
no I upgraded them to that triple
package baby I'm just bam bro that's you
was paying for [ __ ] no yup they were
paying me for nope yeah no because
giving them
means you can't get the money I made
money off them and got [ __ ] now because
you're getting the package you making
less money
right now we really find this out right
now that your wrist was paying money
they paid me bro they paid me you're a
square you're a square bro
we out here yeah
mad girls watch the products because
they stuck the hell off isn't that crazy
that's crazy wait what they watch the
pronos because they sucked you off
because they sucked you off they got to
watch these things is that a bad thing
saying you got a lot of people on that
show I mean it's a great show so thank
you you're welcome yeah thank you you're
welcome yeah
all I'm trying to say is you pay for
[ __ ] bro come on son that [ __ ] is
[ __ ] sad bro that's all you got when
you went out I'll wait for this
[ __ ] to step up I got hit off
you and you ain't can't even give me a
little where's my alley yo
that is exhausted right now it was 36
hours get your ass brutalized in
negotiations